and I think we put a negative label we
oh yeah we want Obsession oh yeah he's
obsessed no it's to me it's a compliment
and a lot of times it can't [__] you up
it can ruin your life you can be
obsessed but I'll tell you one thing if
you want to be great you want to be best
[__] ever at which you do you
could be misunderstood by everybody
because you're going to be so [__]
obsessed and so driven to get there
that's what it takes that's a trick it
takes every second of your [__] life
anybody says balance yeah balance is
important for a lot of [__] people it
is but if you want to [__] go to that
edge where people do not like you don't
understand you question everything you
[__] do you've arrived when people
don't understand you anymore you're in
that spot of obsession and drive where
people like what the [__] is wrong with
this guy I don't want to talk to you man
because you're not going to get it